Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde über ihn gerne berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Herr Schmid ist ein 57-jähriger Patient, der sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern Abend bestehender, plötzlich aufgetretener, erstmaliger, persistierender, ziehender,
rechtsseitiger, hypogastischer Abdominal Schmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung vorstellte.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen nach dem Abendessen aufgetreten und im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala mit 8 von 10 bewertet und zweimalige Einnahme von Ibuprofen 600 mg keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Die Fragen nach Tachikardie, Exzasystole, Papitation, Dyspneum, Tussis, Parasthesis, Hypostesis wurden verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf Insomnie und Inapetenz unauffällig.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Anfängerkrankungen gab er Arteriella Hypatonie seit 15 Jahren, Hyperlipidemie seit 10 Jahren, Asthma-Bonschiele seit 8 Jahren und Paraniche oder Panarithium seit 2 Tagen am Postsee an.
Er nehme Ramipril, also bezüglich der Medikamente nimmt er Ramipril 10 mg morgens, Beloxoc 95 mg morgens, Zortis 10 mg abends, Berodol Spray ein und er benutze Berodol Spray morgens und abends.
Er sei noch nie operiert worden. Er habe Allergie gegen Nickel und Quacksilber.
Diese Allergien äußern sich Exanthem. Er sei Raucher. Er rauche seit 2 Jahren 15 Zigaretten täglich.
Früher habe er 2 Schachteln Zigaretten täglich für 38 Jahre geraucht. Er trinke 2 Flaschen Bier täglich und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er treibe regelmäßig keinen Sport. In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater vor 5 Jahren an Myokardinfarkt mit 72 Jahren verstorben.
Die Mutter sei mit 40 Jahren an Mammakartsinum verstorben. Er sei Einzelkind verheiratet, habe 2 gesunde Töchter.
Der Sohn des Patienten leide an Dyslexie. Er wohne mit seiner Frau zusammen. Er sei Lagerist von Beruf und habe Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Cholestitis aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter seit gestern Abend bestehender rechtsseitiger hypogastischer Abdominal Schmerzen und Übelkeit.
Als Differentialdiagnosen kommen Cholestitis, Pancreatitis, Myokardinfarktus infrage.
Zunächst würde ich den Patienten VITA-Parameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, Schwellungen am Bauch, Murphy-Zeichen, Abwehr, Spannung oder Loslassschmerzen behandelt sind.
Zusätzlich sind eine Röntgen- und Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Röntgen des Abdomens durchführen, um eine Perforation auszuschließen und Lokosystemzahl, CAPBSG, Amylase, Lipase,
Gerüngungsparameter, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Blutgruppe, Herzensime, Lipidophile bestimmen zu lassen.
Außerdem würde ich eine Abdomenssonographie durchführen, um die Gallenblasensteine genau zu beurteilen.
Dagegen würde ich eine CT-Abdomen durchführen, um mögliche Gewebepathologien zu überprüfen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine RACP durchführen, um die Gallensteine oder Koledoko-Thiasis zu bestätigen und wenn es nötig ist, gleichzeitig die Steine zu entfernen.
Ich würde ein LKG schreiben, um Neocardinfarkt auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und ich würde dem Patienten einen Zugang legen.
Wenn es nötig ist, würde ich ausreichende Flüssigkeit zuvor, Spasmodetika, Analytikum, wenn es nötig ist, Antibiotika verabreichen.
Außerdem würde ich ein gastroenterologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie dieser Folgenweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Kollege, in diesem Fall, ECWL empfehlen?
Wenn die Steine über 1 cm sind, können wir ein ESWL durchführen, um die Steine zu verstimmen.
Herr Stümer, können Sie uns über ESWL aufklären?
Ich wusste es. Ihr habt schon geguckt, aber es ist zu schwierig, diese Aufklärung zu lernen.
Das ist eine noninvasive Methode.
Ich würde Sie über ESWL aufklären.
Diese Untersuchung ist eine noninvasive Behandlungsmethode gegen Nieren, Gallenblasen oder Handleitersteine.